Speaker 1: All right.
Let's now go to the next incident from yesterday's
press briefing.
Even though the U.S. and parts of the world
have been dealing with supply chain issues
and shortages delayed shipping times since
the start of the pandemic in March April of
2020, that's been going on now for over a
year, year and a half.
The right now is blaming Joe Biden's transportation
secretary Pete Buttigieg, because he's out
on paternity leave and not fixing the problem,
which I guess is what they believe he should
be doing.
This all came to a humiliating climax yesterday
during the very same White House press briefing
that we've been talking about today.
Jen Psaki fielding a question from Newsmax
reporter Emerald Robinson Emerald Robinson
cited a poll I wasn't able to find, which
supposedly says 65 percent of Americans believe
Pete Boudette judge should get back to work.
He's on paternity leave.
He has premature twins that he's raising.
And Jen Psaki responded, He is at work.
I mean, I had a phone call with him today.
Let's take a look at the clip, and then we're
going to discuss.
Speaker 3: Poll found that sixty five percent
of voters think that given what's going on,
he should go back to work.
He's at work.
He's on paternity leave.
I was on a conference call with him this morning.
He's and he's in the department now every
day.
Listen, Emerald, I think what you're getting
at here is this question about whether men,
parents, women should have paternity and maternity
leave, and the answer is absolutely yes.
Oh God.
In our view, that is the policy of this administration.
That is what we're pressing to make law.
So it's a reality for women, parents, fathers
across the country, and we're not going to
back away from that.
Speaker 1: So there are so many things to
talk about here.
Now, of course, the truth is the entire Pete
Budda judge thing is it's hypocritical.
It's ignorant to some degree, you can argue
it's sexist in the sense that paternity leave
is seen differently than maternity leave by
many on the right and maybe some on the left
as well, but certainly by many on the right.
And it's sort of thinly veiled, or maybe not
so thinly veiled homophobia.
It's both sexist and homophobic, actually,
with regards to Buddha Judge.
So let's let's go through it.
It's hypocritical because first of all.
When Donald Trump was president and Elaine
Chao, Mitch McConnell's wife was the transportation
secretary.
And there were shortages during the pandemic
runs on toilet paper, canned goods, pasta
or pasta as some of our friends in the UK
like to say everything.
No one was claiming that Elaine Chao was responsible.
In fact, nobody even mentioned Elaine Chao
during that time.
So that's the hypocrisy if it's ignorant because
they seem to think we have a system where
the supply chain and transportation infrastructure
depends on one guy.
And if that guy's out because he had twins,
everything breaks down.
If that were the case, it's an absurd system
for a country of 331 million people would
be a pathetic system.
It's not.
The entire supply chain system doesn't depend
on Pete Boudette, judge.
OK, next.
It is sexist because very often paternity
leave is simply not taken as seriously as
maternity leave.
Sometimes it's as simple as who has the breasts.
It's not the guy.
OK, so paternity leave is somehow less legitimate.
We know outcomes are better for kids when
they are spending time with parents early,
you know, all these different things we know.
But there's still this degree to which paternity
leave is just not taken as seriously.
It's a form of sexism.
It's not reverse sexism.
I don't use terms like reverse sexism or reverse
racism.
Is it sexist?
Is it interpreted differently merely because
it's a father rather than a mother?
Yes, that's that's the case.
And it's also slightly veiled homophobia,
because what made people start focusing on
Mayor Pete to begin with Mayor Pete and his
husband, Chasten Chaston, a gay couple that
have adopted twins?
What the focus?
The focus started on Mayor Pete because Tucker
Carlson did this disgusting segment where
he said Mayor Pete's on paternity leave.
What is he learning?
How to breastfeed?
And it's about the feminization of gay men,
et cetera, et cetera.
Gay men want to be women, so Pete Budda judge
would be trying to breastfeed, et cetera.
And then lastly, you know, as Jen Psaki says,
he's not even really fully off or he's working
remotely to some degree.
He's having meetings.
You could argue that's bad.
You could argue, really, he should be able
to be completely off on paternity leave.
We do have a deputy secretary of transportation.
We've got an undersecretary of transportation.
All of this nonsense about the war on Christmas,
toy delays, shipping delays, supply chain,
pet food judge.
It's really all meant to be an attack on Joe
Biden for things they never criticized Trump
over.
That's the big picture they seems.
It seems they don't realize Pete Buddha judge
is actually doing some work anyway.
But then you've got all of the other stuff
wrapped in with it the sexism, the homophobia,
the ignorance, the false belief that the country's
supply chain and logistics infrastructure
depends on one guy.
And Jen Psaki, she went with one approach,
which is he's not really even fully on vacation
like he was on a call today.
And that's like a counterfactual.
But there's all of this other stuff that's
wrapped up an implicit in Emerald Robinson's
question.
And then, by the way, lastly, she said Emerald
65 percent of Americans say Buddha judge should
be back to work.
The opinion of Americans about Buddha Judge's
paternity leave is sort of irrelevant.
But I looked I couldn't find that poll.
I'd maybe the poll exists.
Maybe it's a poll of people who visit the
Newsmax website.
I don't know.
But I was able to find no evidence that that
poll actually exists.
So who knows what that's even based on?
We'll have more clips from this press briefing
on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and follow us on Tik Tok at David
Pakman Show, where we just hit one million
likes a completely arbitrary round number
of likes, which is why I mention it to you
today.
So we've talked quite a bit at this point
this week about the death of former Secretary
of State